la semaine dernière de ma première télé
je sais même pas comment ils ont fait
pour la retrouver parce qu'on ne sait
même pas mon nom de sa suis à la sortie
d'un lycée qui s'appelait le lycée
hélène boucher et regardez la tête c'est
du cac mais surtout le gars mais il
n'est pas concerné on serait pas du tout
parce qu'il se passe
le gars en outre total en fait de tout
ce qu'on dit autour
il est juste en train de mâcher ou
chewing gum mais voilà regarder paris
dans le 19e quelques élèves de
confession israélite ont été amenés à
retirer la kippa alors gérard baud fille
s'est rendue au lycée hélène boucher
mais on en voit dans la cour des grands
et des petits pas et sans voix
non toute façon ils ont leur religion et
parfois qui était comme ça chacun savait
que normalement dans les statuts l'école
doit être là et on doit pas afficher de
signes extérieurs de sa confession
est ce que ça vous paraît dépassé
convention le temps et aux réformes n'a
rien de négatif
la direction est d'avis que ça normal ou
pas normal non
j'aimerais lui ce qu'on va te tais le
gars ne comprend rien il est
complètement tombée alors c'est que tu
comprends rien étudie à la maaf
qu'est-ce qu'il faut cadets mais c'est
qu'elle par cas je les ai vus là-bas
j'ai dit mais quel abruti c'est son nom
est évoqué la place est à vous en foutez
et on bat la brèche et ayrault faisait
mouche le procès n'a en 6e non non non
pas du tout
6e croisés mais non juste une question
comment ça réapparaît sa belle fille je
sais même pas comment ils font pour tous
et non mais vous avez été identifié deux
tiers sur une nouvelle technologie où il
faut les reconnaissances comme sur les
portables de visage et on ne retrouve
plus facilement c'est incroyable non
bassar et elle est là la source du mal
ce moment thierry vous souvenez pas du
tout ce moment et pas du tout c'était
votre move quand même ce que c'est j'ai
l'impression que j'étais sur le banc
alors elle je me rappelle s'appelait
clémentine merci merci à vous en tout
cas de charrière suivi